isaac newton pour voici une énorme
énigme c'est un génie qui littéralement
transcende les lois de la raison dans
les deux sens du terme
d'une part il transcende eu
l'intelligence de la plupart d'entre
nous en tout cas la mienne mais en même
temps il transcende les lois qu'on
accepte communément à propos de la
raison c'est à dire on a tendance à
penser que quelqu'un de raisonnable va
dire des choses raisonnables sa part
être quasiment une tautologie voir une
définition mais l'exemple de newton
notre que c'est pas si facile que c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça alors
j'ai pas parlé de la jeunesse de newton
qui est assez intéressante mais bon
enfant
on va déjà être là pour un petit bout de
temps donc autant sauter cette partie on
va commencer directement lorsque newton
à 18 ans et qu'il rentre à trinity
college
ce moment-là 120 qu'ultra curieux du
monde autour de lui et il le restera
toute sa vie à m curieux et en
particulier à ce moment là il veut
comprendre la nature et en particulier
les lumières et pour ça il va faire des
expériences complètement folle quoi une
forêt noire dans les deux sens du terme
encore une fois c'est l'air que d'une
part il va se mettre en danger
physiquement pour pouvoir faire des
espaces notamment une des expériences
qui fait c'est qu'il prend une aiguille
et il va presser le l'arrière de son
oeil pour voir comment la modification
de la courbure de son deuil affecte sa
vision il va se rendre compte à ce
moment là qu'il y avait couleurs qui
apparaissent il ya des aberrations
niveau des couleurs qu'ils voient du
fait de ce changement de la forme
géométrique de son deuil et cette
expérience va nous amener à réfléchir
davantage à la nature de l'umih
avait faire notamment une expérience à
ces fameuses est vraiment folle cette
fois dans l'autre sens du terme on va
dire à prendre la lumière du soleil il
va mettre un prisme qui va diviser cette
couleur en couleur blanche de lumière du
soleil en différentes couleurs
et puis var combiner ses couleurs et ça
ça va montrer quelque chose d'assez
incroyable à savoir le fait que la
lumière blanche ne peut pas être pensé
comme la lumière pure et les couleurs
des couleurs de la lumière un pur
puisqu'en fait une combinaison de
couleurs un pur re donne cette couleur
blanche est en fait une zone va
comprendre qu'il vaut mieux penser la
lumière blanche comme la combinaison
voir l'addition comme on apparaît dans
un épisode précédent des différentes
couleurs de l'arc en ciel
et quand je parle d'addition en fait je
parle de vrais addition d'une addition
mathématiques une édition vectorielle
même si cette addition de victoria en
fait elle n'existait pas à l'époque de
houston open anachronismes toujours est
il qu'en comprenant mieux la nature de
la lumière du town va être conduit à
penser qu'il aime limite physique
théorique fondamentale à la lunette de
galilée
si on essaie d'avoir des lunettes qui
voit encore plus loin en fait on va
finir par avoir des aberrations niveau
des couleurs
du coup il ya une limite physique à haut
potentiel de cette lunette de galilée
qui d'ailleurs n'est pas
même inventé par gagner contrairement ce
que j'ai dit dans un épisode précédent
et du coup ils newton va se mettre au
défi de construire une alternative voire
tout simplement améliorer sa technologie
et il va y arriver il va construire un
télescope dit par réflexion c'est à dire
okoyo d'utiliser démenti il veut
utiliser des miroirs paraboliques et
ainsi newton va créer un télescope qui a
la foi est plus petit mais qui permet
aussi de voir plus loin que la lunette
de galilée et ça ça va faire sensation
il va devenir super connu avec çà et là
notamment devenir professeur à cambridge
et il va intégrer la world society en
angleterre et du coup il va être amené à
parler de la nature de la lumière à ses
collègues qui vont lui demander une
version du critique où il est créé un
article qui va être soumis à la re
lecture et l'éveil se fait défoncer il
se fait défoncer par un certain robin
cook qui va devenir le véritable bébé 6
10 avec clinton pour qui la dire qu'en
gros du tout on parle de choses que vous
qui a déjà fait ou de choses fausses
et du coup du town va être
incroyablement vexé il va se dire scrute
il va dire j'arrête de publier des
articles scientifiques et pendant 20 ans
et va vivre tel un ermite enfermé chez
lui à faire des expériences
scientifiques dawson cours
donc personne ne sera au courant
notamment dans cette période il a il va
commencer à s'attaquer à l'alchimie qui
va devenir une activité majeure de
newton il va en particulier partir à la
recherche de la pierre philosophale
cette pierre qui permettrait de
transformer les météos en or de guérir
de maladie et peut-être même de
permettre l'immortalité
alors on peut se moquer de newton et de
cette recherche de l'alchimie ceci dit
newton est un incroyable génie est
vraiment vraiment 20
vraiment comme on en parlera un peu plus
tard il écrit le bouquin le plus
important de l'histoire des sciences et
du coup ça peut pas être très surprenant
de se dire que ce mec ultra rationnelle
ce mec est une intelligence qui
transcende eu l'intelligence de la quasi
totalité de l'espèce une win
comment se fait-il que ce mec se décide
à faire de l'alchimie quand j allais
chemise c'est qu'il va lire des textes
l'ancien interpréter ces textes anciens
en terme de matériaux lorsque c'était
enfin c'est en parlerons de dieu ou 2 ou
2 sais pas trop quoi il va interpréter
que en fait tel dieu est représenté
telle matière il faut mélanger telle
matière telle matière sont dit que tel
dieu tutelle diouf sait pas trop quoi il
va imaginer qu'à l'inter de ces textes
de façon codée se trouve une recette
pour la pierre philosophale
comment est-ce qu'un mec comme ça comme
layton a pu penser ça ça paraît surtout
que je dis à luton voyais contredit
aristote à longueur de journée quoi du
coup une fois que newton contredit
aristote ou est d'accord en tout cas
avec galilée qui contredit aristote
comment peut-il encore accorder quelque
crédit que ce soit à les textes anciens
ça paraît ça paraît déraisonnable et
j'ai beaucoup de mal à l'expliquer alors
une explication qui pond couvent être
très partiel à ça si c'est que newton
lui-même adoré vivre dans le secret et
notamment ils envoyaient des messages
temps à leibniz qui était entièrement
codé
du coup il y avait l'habitude de parler
de manière très codé et il se disait que
dans le temps et la vie bien avoir
d'autres très très très grands génies
qui avait découvert des trucs
incroyables et mais qui était entouré
d'incapables eux aussi se disait newton
et que du coup ils préféraient
communiqués demain
secrète à d'autres gens qui seront
suffisamment intelligents pour bien
interpréter ces codes secrets du coup du
taux de se disait que c'est jenny
antique devait communiquer avec newton
ainsi et c'est peut-être pour cela qu'il
a donné du crédit à des textes qui
n'avait l'air d'avoir aucun sens photo
kc une explication partielle que j'ai
l'autre remarque que je ferai c'est que
l'alchimie de newton était
incroyablement rigoureuse était
incroyablement réfléchi extrêmement
scientifique serre qu'il mesurait
précisément les quantités qui mélangeait
il faisait vraiment gaffard exactement
ce qu'ils faisaient ils notaient tous
ceux qui faisaient qu il chercher de
l'inspiration dans les expériences
qu'ils avaient tenté précédemment pour
déterminer quelle a été la prochaine
expérience qu'il fallait faire pour
mieux comprendre aux telle ou telle
direction et au final quand on y
réfléchit c'est une approche peut-être
pas si différente de la chimie
d'aujourd'hui alors je dis ça je ne suis
pas chimiste donc je dis peut-être une
énorme boulette dans la résidence
binaire en plaindra si vous êtes
chimiste je vous invite à me contredire
dès à présent rapport à ce que je dis
mais il me semble pour avoir parlé à des
amis chimiste que en chine aujourd'hui
ce qu'on fait beaucoup
c'est chercher à mélanger des produits
donc dont on ne comprend pas forcément
tous mais on est guidé par d'autres
expériences qui ont été faites et puis
on cherche à faire pleins d'expérience à
noter tout ce qu on le fait à prendre en
compte les mesures identité que l'on
mélange et on explore ainsi le monde de
la chimie
finalement d'une manière pas si
différente de la manière dont
newton explorer le monde de l'alchimie
donc pour résumer nutritifs et de
l'alchimie
c'est troublant mais on peut peut-être
trouver les explications dans ces
troubles en clair mais ce n'est pas
aussi troublant que la découverte qui a
été fait
une redécouverte des écrits de niton où
vous voyez clairement que newton a passé
le plus clair de son temps à faire de la
théologie à se poser des questions sur
l'existence de dieu avait été de la
bible la divinité du christ et tout ça
hilton avait ainsi plus de 30 bible et
il l'aimé croiser les informations de
toutes ces bibles voir tout ce qu'ils
différaient d'une bible à l'autre il en
est venu notamment la conclusion que du
gros passages qui parlait de la divinité
du christ avait été rajouté quatre
siècles après jésus-christ du coup
n'avait aucune validité et du coup il
s'agissait d'une hérésie que de
considérer que le christ était aussi
divin que dieu alors je ne suis
absolument pas théologien je n'ai pas
envie de dire des boulettes et je ne
veux pas envie de parler de théologie
mais je tiens tout de même à signaler
qu'après toutes ces études de des écrits
newton déjà avait dépensé hérétiques
qu'il garda secrète toute sa vie parce
que si elles étaient les plus hardis se
faire au moins viré de son poste de
professeur sinon pire mais aussi que
newton en est arrivé à prédire
l'apocalypse c'est la fin du monde
en 2060 c'est pour bientôt
et enfin que newton en fait brûler la
quasi-totalité de ses textes sur la
théologie
juste avant de mourir ce qui suggère que
dans ces textes là il y avait des trucs
encore plus à l'hérétique est encore
plus farfelues que newton aurait pensé
du danieli et rubans pas clair des trucs
complètement bizarre il a fait ce qu'on
appellerait aujourd'hui de la pseudo
science
comment est ce possible qu'un mec aussi
raisonnable aussi si logique aussi
rationnel aussi scientifique clinton ait
pu avoir des pensées aussi ils sont la
visite de riley dont je parlerai dans la
prochaine vidéo
newton serait mort ainsi en tant que
théologien inconnu et ne serait pas du
tout reconnu comme scientifique
malgré son traité sur l'optique tout cas
on n'aurait pas su ces lois de la
gravitation n'aurait pas su à quel point
c'était un véritable génie et on ne
serait pas tombé sur cette contradiction
mais incroyable entre le génie des
sciences le mec qui a écrit et lepron
qui pia mathematica le livre le plus
important de l'histoire des sciences
pour en compétition avec les éléments
d'euclide qui me semble une influence au
moins aussi grande que comme tu perds
mathematica mais enfin c'est juste un
livre un quad le quotidien mathematica
puis a fait des mathématiques des tonnes
d'un très très haut niveau
il a cherché à rationaliser à comprendre
le monde
quand se fait-il que newton puis avoir
de telles pensées pseudo-scientifiques
peu réseau train pas raisonnable en fait
même dans le plus petit qu'un
mathématiques à newton résout le
problème qu'on appelle le problème des
deux corps qui est un problème
mathématique assez jolie qui pas facile
à résoudre une tonne contre lui étaient
dues mathématiques super sophistiqué
pour résoudre ce problème et résout se
prennent donc le fameux des deux corps
c'est une planète qui tourne autour à
sol est typiquement puis après newton se
pose la question des trois corps c'est
que ce facile si au lieu d'avoir
une planète une semaine un soleil qui
sait pas si on a trois soleils disons
qui orbitent les un autre des autres et
après qu'est ce qui se passe au niveau
du système solaire où il ya pas mal de
planètes qui s'influencent
gravitationnellement et newton en vain
on vient à écrire des phrases
complètement un pseudo scientifiques
souvent c'est assez étrange part du
personnage c'est à dire que newt inde
écrit par exemple le système solaire est
trop compliquée pour être résolus alors
c'est à dire peut-être aussi du fait
qu'à l'époque
les mathématiques sont très limités on
pense que si on n'arrive pas à résoudre
une équation avec des formules bien
connu alors il est impossible de
résoudre l'équation
quoi qu'il arrive que du coup aussi bon
on n'arrive pas à résoudre vraiment
l'équation
eh bien il faut un être suprême outre et
c'est ce que dit newton connaître divin
d'yeux que pour résoudre ces dépressions
il justifie quasiment l'existence de
dieu par le fait qu'il n'arrive pas à
résoudre une équation par exemple pas
rationnel dans ce qui paraît vraiment
pas comment un mec aussi logique aussi
intelligent aussi puissant qu'une eaton
aussi si douée que newton avait pu voir
ce genre de réflexion très peu justifiée
ça me fait très mal de le dire en tant
que vulgarisateur scientifique
moi j'ai envie que les gens croient
qu'il suffit d'apprendre les sciences et
les maths surtout pour complètement
comprendre le monde autour d'eux mais
l'exemple de newton montre que ce n'est
pas le lien il ya quelque chose de plus
fort que ça me semble qu'ils aient une
influence subtil de l'environnement qui
nous entoure de ce que les autres autour
de nous penser de la manière dont il
nous affecte
il affecte notre façon de penser du cas
c'est un truc qui chasse il faut voir
enfin ça vaut vraiment le coup de
beaucoup réfléchir à ça et voir à
chercher à comprendre dans le newton et
à comprendre plus généralement pourquoi
les gens pensent ce qu'ils pensent y
compris
lorsqu'ils sont incroyablement
intelligent incroyablement plus
intelligent que nos autres cas que en
tout cas que moi j'espère que ça vous
pousse à montrer qu'il faut faire preuve
d'énormément de prudence lorsque l'on
parle notamment de choses et à la
théologie ou spiritualiser truc où le
truc comme ça puisque même un mec qui a
le niveau de rigueur de newton a fini
par dire d énorme bêtise
lorsqu'il en est venu à parler de ce à
quoi je pense que je peux finir cette
vidéo avec une citation des tim cain il
faut se hâter de ne pas conclure c'est
peut-être une leçon d'humilité qu'il
faut retirer de cette histoire et ne pas
trop chercher à conclure et accepter le
fait qu'on est très ignorants
j'en profite pour vous recommander les
deux vidéos sur la vie de newton par
balade mental où il qualifie à très
juste titre newton de savants flou il
faut dire qu'il a été la première star
scientifique de son vivant